las protestas no cesan en Perú en 10 de
sus 25 regiones varias carreteras
continúan bloqueadas el pedido de los
manifestantes es el mismo la dimisión de
la presidenta Gina boluarte el
aeropuerto de cusco que permite Acceder
al Machu Picchu fue cerrado por
prevención en la capital Lima miles de
personas se reunieron de forma pacífica
este jueves a la llamada de sindicatos y
partidos de izquierda denuncian las
muertes en las protestas que llegan casi
al medio centenar
que la están utilizando
por qué usted está dando la espalda al
pueblo son tantas muertes por Dios paren
con toda esta masacre no es justo Yo sé
que la gente que está saliendo a
protestar es gente que está indignada
como yo y no nos está interrumpiendo que
no somos terrucos entre tanto el
ministro de trabajo Eduardo García
virimiza presentó su dimisión en una
carta a la presidenta en la cual instó
el gobierno a pedir disculpas y
organizar elecciones anticipadas se
requiere que se pida disculpas a la
población y que se reconozca que se han
cometido errores y que deben ser
corregidos para que esto no se repita la
situación amerita un cambio de rostros
en la dirección del país y un adelanto
de elecciones que no puede ya esperar
hasta abril de 2024 Pero vive una
intensa ola de manifestaciones así como
el peor brote de violencia en décadas
consecuencia de la destitución del
presidente Pedro Castillo a principio de
diciembre tras sus intentos por disolver
el congreso a través una delegación
Interamericana de Derechos Humanos llegó
al país suramericano para verificar la
situación de los Derechos Humanos